الثامنة صباحًا، درجة حرارة
حمام السباحة 58 درجة، أوه، بارد جدًا،
كل المشاهير
والمؤثرين يغوصون في المياه الجليدية في
جميع أنحاء وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي، لا يمكنك الشعور
بقدمي أو يدي، ليست هناك
ظاهرة جديدة، إنها مجرد الشيء
الجديد  يتعلق الأمر بعدد الأشخاص الذين
يقومون بذلك الآن، هذا هو البروفيسور مايك تيبتون
من مختبر البيئات القاسية
بجامعة بورتسموث في إنجلترا، حيث
درس تأثيرات ومخاطر
الحرارة والبرودة الشديدة على جسم الإنسان.
البشر حيوانات استوائية نريد أن نكون
حيث تطورنا وهو نوع من الشرق إلى الجنوب الشرقي
والآن هذا يعني أن الدخول إلى
الماء البارد أمر مرهق للغاية، فالعلم
حول فوائد الغطس غامض،
لدينا بعض الفرضيات حول كيفية
عمل البرد حتى يتم
إجراء الدراسات التي يتم التحكم فيها بشكل صحيح  لا يمكننا
التأكد ولكن تيبتون يقول إن التغلب على
تحدي الغمر في الماء البارد قد
يساهم في بعض الفوائد، لديك
مرونة عقلية في متناول يدك، لديك
إنتاجية، تركيزك، لديك
مثل هذا الإحساس البهيج،
تحصل على مجموعة من الطاقة التي أحصل عليها بالتأكيد
هذا الاندفاع الذي يشبه الأدرينالين والسيروتونين
والدوبامين
يثير استجابة القتال أو الطيران وجزء
من هذه الاستجابة هو إطلاق
هرمونات التوتر، لذا فإن الذهاب إلى
الماء البارد سوف يوقظك على
الجانب الآخر، فهناك مجموعة كاملة من
استجابات يحتمل أن تكون خطرة
ترتبط بفعل ذلك، وفقًا
لتيبتون، في أول 30 ثانية
تحدث سلسلة من التفاعلات، يمتص الماء البارد
الحرارة بعيدًا أسرع بخمس مرات من
درجة حرارة الهواء، ويسقط بسرعة مسببًا
شهقة لا يمكن السيطرة عليها،
ويوقف فرط التنفس تدفق الدم إلى الجلد
ويزيد الدم.  الضغط المعروف
باسم استجابة الصدمة الباردة التي
يستجيب لها Cold Shot يمثل حوالي 60
شخصًا يموتون عند الذهاب إلى الماء البارد
وهذا خطير بشكل خاص إذا
كنت تعاني من ارتفاع ضغط الدم إذا كنت مصابًا
بمرض تمدد الأوعية الدموية في القلب والأوعية الدموية
وتاريخيًا كنا نعتقد  أن
أخطر رد فعل على الغمر في
الماء البارد هو انخفاض حرارة الجسم
والأرجح أنه من خلال الدخول في الماء البارد
بشكل متكرر أو لفترات طويلة
سوف تحصل على ما نسميه إصابة البرد غير المتجمدة
وهذا ضرر
للألياف العصبية الصغيرة والدم  الأوعية الدموية ويمكن أن
تؤدي إلى إعاقة مدى الحياة
لأولئك الذين يرغبون في تجربتها.
ينصح تيبتون بالتأكد من أن الطبيب يخلصك
من المخاطر القلبية وعدم القيام بالغطس
بمفردك أبدًا،
ويقترح أيضًا تجنب الماء البارد الذي تقل درجة حرارته
عن 59 درجة فهرنهايت أو 15 درجة
مئوية والحد من الغطس إلى 5 درجات.  إلى 10
دقائق كحد أقصى، ستحصل على ما تحتاجه في
الدقائق القليلة الأولى من الغطس،
ليست هناك حاجة للبقاء لفترة أطول
وتذكر أن هناك طرقًا أكثر أمانًا ومثبتة
للحصول على بعض هذه الفوائد ولكننا نعلم
حقيقة أن التمرين يوفر الكثير.
من بين هذه التغييرات المفيدة في
الصحة العقلية والجسدية، فكر أكثر مثل
الرياضيين المفضلين لديك على التلفاز في الملعب
وأقل مثلهم على الجليد، لذلك نطلب روي أون
ذا روكس، هاه